hello and welcome to the take with
Sophie Ridge live at nine here in the
heart of Westminster so is this the week
that Rishi sunak finally left the past
behind he's promised to stop the small
boat it's a controversial policy some
would say was impossible to deliver but
it certainly generated debate with that
and his very own brexit deal he's been
trying to step out at the shadow of
Boris Johnson but the former prime
minister is never far from the headlines
with our latest Westminster accounts
investigation finding that Mr Johnson
earned a call at 3.7 million pounds this
year far more than any other MP so we'll
have more on that later on the show as
we bring you takes from all sides over
the next 60 minutes
on this matter he talked about his legal
background he's just another Lefty
lawyer standing in our way
things got pretty heated at promises
questions over the small boats policy so
what did the man accused of being a
lefty lawyer make of it
after 13 years Small Boat Crossings
higher than ever claims unprocessed the
taxpayer paying for hotel rooms criminal
gangs running all the way laughing to
the bank
well on the program today we will Deep
dive into the small boats policy who is
right and we're going to have a top
lineup of guests to do that with
including the immigration Minister
Robert generick we'll also be talking to
you the shadow attorney general Emily
Thornbury
and on International women's day we are
going to be speaking to Siobhan Haviland
the director general of the British
Chambers of Commerce and much publicized
too on the take
[Music]
[Applause]
good evening well it's been a week so
far dominated by the small boats route
is it a policy that's workable or just
another dividing line in the culture War
we'll be hearing from labor and the
government shortly but let's start shall
we with some of the best bits of the
week so far
prime minister Under Fire this morning
over his plans to tackle Small Boat
Crossings the government wants
immigration to become a dividing light
with labor at the next election they
know this is traditional safe Tory
ground that could sway votes the trouble
is it's not just about talking tough on
immigration it's about delivery if you
come here illegally you can't claim
Asylum you can't benefit from our modern
slavery protections and you can't stay
this is their fifth prime minister their
sixth immigration plan their seventh
Home Secretary and after all this time
all they offer is the same old gimmicks
and empty promises what's important is
that we do need to take uh compassionate
but necessary and fair measures now
because there are people who are dying
to try and get here there's hundreds of
thousands of people are taking part in
demonstrations rallies and events around
the world to Mark International women's
day vendor pickup was 12 higher than it
was in 2020 and can anyone on the
government front bench please apologize
to women for that increase this
International women's day can I ask the
prime minister to reconfirm the under
his proposed new Asylum was a woman who
is sex trafficked to the UK on a small
boat by a criminal gang will not be
afforded protection under our modern
slavery laws it's precisely because we
want to Target our resources and our
compassion on the world's most
vulnerable people that we need to get a
grip of this system make sure that we
have control over our borders make sure
our our system and resources are not
overwhelmed
well as you can tell the policy or
migrants who cross the channel really
dominated at Prime Minister's questions
today so that's the first thing I asked
when I spoke to the immigration Minister
Robert generick earlier this evening
are you going to be able to stop the
small boats well that's our objective we
couldn't have been clearer in putting it
as one of the five central Promises of
this government to stop the boat secure
our borders and bring fairness back to
our Asylum system we're going to do
everything in our power to achieve that
and ultimately it will be for the public
to decide at the next general election
whether we've succeeded or not but being
no doubt that the prime minister of the
home sector and I will do everything we
can to achieve that goal
listening to some of the language you're
using there it's your objective you're
going to do everything you can to
achieve it not saying yeah we are going
to stop the small boat we are going to
to stop the small boats and we will do
everything that we can it's a complex
challenge it would be wrong of me to
pretend otherwise that's why we're going
to pull every lever at our disposal from
the legislation that we've presented to
Parliament this week to the Diplomatic
front that the prime minister is
continuing tomorrow or Friday in in
Paris with president macron to the work
that I'm doing with the security
services and the police to toughen up
our approach Upstream to the criminal
gangs we're going to do everything
possible to resolve this are we going to
be paying the French more
well we've already given them further
funding in the arrangement that we
reached at the end of last year and that
was for work that is now happening we're
seeing are we going to give them more
money
you'll have to wait and see what the
Prime Minister agrees with president
macron at the end of the week but not
ruling it out what we're seeking to
achieve is a number of things one of
which is more police officers French
officers on the beaches and the
hinterland of them in northern France so
they would intercept as many of these
boats as possible and the moment the
French are actually intercepting 50 of
them so that's meaningful to us the more
we can do on that front the better and
we also want our intelligence services
to be cooperating and working together
in real time so that when we learn about
what the criminal gangs are doing we get
that information to our French
counterparts and they take action we're
very clear-eyed about how tough this is
we need to be robust against these
criminal gangs because they're amongst
the most organized and evil people in
society today I just want to have a look
at some of the practicalities of this
well so you're saying that if you enter
the UK illegally not three legal routes
then you will not be able to claim
Asylum so what then happens to those
people like you could understand you
we've got return agreements with certain
countries like Albania but there's lots
of other countries where many many
people come from that we don't and like
Syria for example 4 500 people arriving
from Syria last year you're not going to
just pick up the phone to Assad are you
well that's the reason why we need safe
third countries like Rwanda and we want
to get that Arrangement up and running
as soon as possible I was very pleased
to see at the end of last year that the
high court upheld it as a legal policy
it's being appealed at the moment it
will be before the court of appeal next
month assuming that that has a similar
positive judgment for the government
then will operationalize that as quickly
as we can let's get real on Rwanda right
45 000 people your figures um crossing
the channel last year in small boats
Rwanda initially agrees to take 200
people
period that's not correct I mean not the
only journalists who have said that but
the scheme of the round is uncapped so
the Rwandan government and we've spoken
to them again this week Rasheed student
spoke to Paul kagami his opposite number
they're willing to take as many people
as is required completely unlimited
unlimited arrangement we don't think
it's going to take anything like that
that's your estimate then it's the
number of people who you're expecting to
send to Rwanda well we'll take as many
we'll set as many people as is required
no because what we expect will happen is
that this will break once and for all
the people Smugglers have you done it
we've worked through scenarios and the
Australian uh experience shows is that
within weeks once it's clear that you
will not spend uh time in the UK or in
Australia in that case uh people will
stop making the journey so what I expect
to see is that we will operationalize
this policy a very large number of
people will need to go there in the
initial weeks and months but then it
will be very large well it depends how
many people are crossing the channel at
that time but if it requires thousands
of people to be sent to Rwanda then we
will send thousands of people since that
you launched the scheme in April well
well none because it's been caught
that's my point right in our course that
makes that makes the point pretty well
though doesn't it you said that there
are complex issues well I don't think it
does because the legal ramifications of
this which are going to be extensive
well the good news is stuck on the
bright side so it is that the court of
appeal is hearing the case and we expect
that it will come to a similar judgment
to the high court which said that the
policy was lawful if that's the case
then we should be able to get this
policy up and running quite quickly and
we will remove as many people as is
required to have the deterrent effect
and then I think you'll start to see the
numbers crossing the channel 4 very
rapidly and that's the key thing here
because we want deterrence to be
suffused throughout our approach so that
we break the model of the people
smuggling gangs we don't want people to
be risking their lives spending their
life savings at the best of these evil
criminals we want to bring order and
fairness back to the Asylum system what
are you going to do with children
well what we've said is that if you come
with your family then you will be part
of the scheme so you'll be detained as a
family group and you will then be
removed either to your home country if
it's safe to do so or to Rwanda you
could send families with young children
to Rwanda that is we could do and let me
just explain why that matters because
there's a there's a difficult decision
at the heart of this which you're right
to to pick up on but if we didn't do
that then what we would see is people
smuggling gangs preying upon families or
people purporting to be families and
specializing in bringing those people
across the channel in small boats and I
don't want to see that I don't want
children to be at the behest of people
Smugglers I've met children and families
who have just arrived on our Shores
where we've literally saved their lives
at Sea and as a parent that is a
shocking and horrible thing to see and
so by removing families I think we'll
have the deterrent effect that's
required so they stay in France which is
obviously a safe place and is where a
family seeking protection should remain
but could also be sent as you say to
third countries under the scheme how
about unaccompanied children
unaccompanied children will be given a
short bridging leave so they'll remain
in the UK until they turn 18 and then at
that point they will be removed either
back home if their home country is a
safe place or to a safe Third Country
like Rwanda again what we don't want to
see is the UK being exploited by people
smuggling gowns who Prey Upon children
or those people who are purporting to be
children that would be wrong what
happens to them in this bridging period
then well they would remain in the UK
and they'd be cared for uh by local
authorities in the way that they are
today for a short period remember that
most of the miners that we receive as a
country today who are unaccompanied are
16 or 17 year old males who are here for
mainly for work in the in the black
economy what we would do is uh look
after them for that short period
appropriately and you know decently
compassionately but then we would remove
them afterwards because I think the
alternative would be that the people
smokers will be bringing over children
and also adults would be purporting to
be children which creates all sorts of
safeguarding risks that we just don't
want as a country I just want to talk a
little bit about
um
the fact that many people would say
there are no safe and legal routes or
few safe and legal routes for people who
are not from
Ukraine from Afghanistan from Hong Kong
where we have this established process
to get into the country they're
desperate this is why they're making the
journey in the first place uh many from
countries where
they clearly have human rights issues
they're not all economic migrants as you
say now I just want to play what Chris
hit and Harris told me on the program on
uh Sunday uh about safe and legal roots
I'm just quite sure there'll be more
safe and legal routes and that's why
um you know and that's why we have them
and you're quite right they've been
proven to work so he told me there will
be more safe and legal routes is that
right are you looking at opening it is
the bill says uh is that we will create
a new safe and legal route as a country
and that will be one which has a set
quota we will consult annually local
authorities to see what capacity they
have in terms of Housing and school
places to support those people
appropriately and then the Home
Secretary of the day will come to
Parliament and seek parliamentary
approval for that and I think that's
quite a grown-up mature way of handling
this situation where we do have a safe
and legal route but it's one which is
rooted in the true capacity of local
authorities so that we don't have people
in hotels or clearly inappropriate
accommodation and we can set that number
at a level that means we can look after
people in the way that you or I on the
British would expect I I would just
having said that take issue with the
premise of the question which is that
the UK is somehow ungenerous oh that's
not that's not what I'm saying well
that's absolutely not one last year I I
didn't say that at all what I'm saying
is that there are safe and legal routes
for people coming from some countries
and no safe and legal routes from other
countries which means you have that's
not quite true for for some countries
you're right to say the UK has been
incredibly generous like Ukraine Hong
Kong Syria Afghanistan and quite rightly
so to the point that last year we issued
more humanitarian visas than any year
since the end of the second world war
almost half a million since 2015 but
there are already safe and legal routes
from other countries we have a
resettlement scheme where we work with
the UN HCR which is operating in those
countries where there are conflicts or
serious human rights abuses which people
can apply to but but I also don't think
the UK can just offer support to anyone
in any any part of the world it's right
that we focus our finite resources on
those places and people to whom we've
got so that's geographical moral
historical obligation yeah that's the
point all countries do that in the world
I think that's that's completely
understandable
um I just want to get your reaction to
tweet by Gary lineker at the footballer
who's taken issue with the scheme on
moral ground he said there is no huge
influx we take far fewer refugees than
other major European countries this is
just an immeasurably cruel policy
directed at the most vulnerable people
in language that's not dissimilar to
that used by Germany in the 30s and I'm
out of order
well firstly on the language that he
uses I think that is inflammatory and
wrong you shouldn't throw around
comparisons with the Nazis and 1930s
Germany he should choose his language
carefully just as politicians should do
and I suspect he's been in the public
eye long enough to know exactly the kind
of reaction that he was going to provoke
but on the policy he's also wrong
because unlike Gary lineker I see every
day in my job what the evil people
smuggling gangs are actually doing and
yes
cruel and heartless what he's talking
people are dying as a result of their
activities and the only way to break
their business model is to implement a
policy so talking about though is that
we take fewer refugees than other major
European countries and actually if you
look at applications made in 2021 uh per
head per 100 000 population you know we
are quite a long way down at the list
aren't we and Germany France Switzerland
Netherlands Spain well it depends how
you how you look at the figures I mean
if you look at the homes for Ukraine
scheme that is that's not that is twice
the size of the French equivalent just
you're just using one example of deaf
people I think it's like the overall
it's a really significant scheme you're
talking about yeah about 150 000 the
overall refugees
okay let me answer and let me answer a
different way then if you look at the
countries who take people on safe and
legal routes organized by the unhcr we
are the fourth largest recipient of
those individuals of any developed
countries in the world that overall
figures you're looking at well I'm
looking at the countries in terms of how
would you measure a country's
willingness to embrace those people who
are in greatest Eden
is
another major European countries well I
don't think that's correct I mean
obviously they're a countries like
Poland who borders you know that
position within Europe means that
inevitably very large numbers of people
have crossed them they've welcomed them
in a compassionate manner but the
schemes that we have put forward in
recent years are incredibly generous and
compassionate and that will always
continue you're still going to watch
much of the day
yeah of course so well I like watching
Gary lineker I just don't always enjoy
his tweets and think he should choose
his language more carefully okay thank
you very much thank you
but generic there the immigration
Minister well let's get the Labor's take
uh now shall we on the small boats
policy and also uh on uh Gary lineker
too who's been generating quite a lot of
uh headlines uh today I spoke to the uh
Shadow Italian General Emily Thornbury
I want to talk to you about the
government's policy on small boats it's
very clear they say that they want to
try and stop the small boats by saying
anyone who enters the UK illegally won't
be able to make a claim for Asylum
would a labor government keep that
policy
we don't think it works I mean we want
to stop the small boats as well it's
just that we don't just want to talk
tough we actually want to take some
action and soella bravman has said you
know that people are fed up with tough
talk and no action and she's right and
this legislation that they're trying to
pass is very similar to the legislation
they tried nine months ago and that
didn't work you know I like the
legislation from nine months ago they
identified 18 000 people who they said
had no right to be in the UK and how and
in the last year how many of them have
they sent back 21. you know this is just
rhetoric this is posturing and it's not
a plan so you're stopping the small bit
I'm just trying to work out do you
object to the government's policy purely
on practical grounds because you don't
think it will work or do you objective
or moral grounds too on principle I
think first first and foremost we want
to stop the small boats and we want to
take action that's going to work we
think that it is wrong that the
government is trying to posture we are
concerned about some of the
small boats but the principle that if
you enter the UK legally you shouldn't
be able to claim Asylum do you agree
with that well I think our concern is
that there will be amongst those people
some people who are genuine refugees and
there will be people who are taking the
Mickey and what we should be doing is
making decisions and making decisions
fast essentially we think that we should
have a a firm fair and fast immigration
Asylum system but instead what we've got
is we've got hotels clogged up we've got
them wanting to open up you know all
kinds of camps and just lock people up
in them if you were let's say a um an
interpreter for the army in Afghanistan
you know the people who have been able
to come out and get Asylum have already
gone you know the helicopters have gone
the planes have gone people are now
stuck and they've been told by the
government to make their way to Britain
and claim Asylum but there isn't a way
legally of coming to Britain as an
Afghan now well that's so true there is
there is an Afghanistan
it's finished it's not possible to get I
mean okay so so even it so so yes you'd
be able once you claim it then you can
claim but like where do you do it and
how do you do it the government has said
make your way here so if you did make
your way here illegally and then claim
through the system I want that they go
no no sorry you've come illegally we
can't even process in Afghanistan there
is a legal route to claim Asylum you
cannot get from Afghanistan to the UK
legally so you have to I mean there
aren't any flights you can't get there
so you have to go you have to make your
own way to the UK but not for
Afghanistan though there is a there is a
resettlement program for Afghanistan but
they but the government has said that
people should make their way because
except from other countries Syria for
example Iran Iraq but for Afghanistan
there is you can argue about the figures
and the fact that very few people have
come under it but there is a route a
large number of people came right a
large number of people came but then
there was a cut off and now I mean I
have a constituent who's who went back
to get his wife and now can't get back
to Britain because there aren't any
flights and so he's having to take her
you know over into Pakistan and then was
hoping to try to get the two of them
into the UK but whether they're able to
get out of Afghanistan Pakistan is a big
question you know particularly given
that he has a British passport it's I
mean the whole thing is really very
difficult and you slip into you know
illegally traveling very easily very
quickly in order to try to get Asylum
which is what people are doing anyway
this is a longer side the point is this
right is that there will be people
amongst those who arriving in small
boats who are genuine refugees and the
government's policy now will be we don't
care you've come illegally we will put
you into a camp and you will have no
rights and we will well I don't know
what they're going to do I mean because
they can't send anybody back anywhere so
what what are they going to do with all
these people and they don't answer that
what they should be working on is they
should be working on a system whereby
they can return people and coming up
with some agreements with other
countries which is what they say they
are well they're not you know I mean
pretty Patel was banned from France if
you remember because of the remarks that
she'd made they were having discussions
and they said we're not going to have
your Home Secretary they have you know
the broken the broken immigration and
Asylum system is the fault of the
government and the government had been
in power for 13 years and they have
broken it
um Gary lineker has the football
presenter has criticized the policy as
immeasurably cruel
do you think it's appropriate for
someone who works at the BBC who accepts
money from the license payer to use
their platform to make political
statements
I know that Gary lineker feels very
strongly about this issue and he has
introduced I mean he's brought
refugees into his home he campaigns on
this issue I think some of the language
that Gary lineker has used in the last
24 hours has been really very
unfortunate and I wouldn't have used
some of those people talking about the
comparison to Germany yeah I don't I
just think that there is a special place
in hell for the Nazism for the Holocaust
I don't think that you should be making
comparisons
um so I wouldn't have said that I think
that he went too far but what the BBC
does about it is frankly not my business
it's not for me to time maybe see what
they do
um and um you know it'll be up to them
if they want to do anything about it but
otherwise I'm sure he will continue to
say what he thinks yeah it certainly
seems that he doesn't tend to do that
um I want to talk to you a little bit
about anti-Semitism because Luciano
Berger returned to the labor party four
years after stepping down accusing the
party of anti-Semitism under Jeremy
corbyn and Kristoff apologized for what
he described as her intolerable and
unacceptable experience do you agree
that she had an unacceptable experience
yeah
I just wonder because obviously both you
can this time we're in Jeremy corbyn's
Shadow cabinet you know you used to buy
him you campaigned for him you tried to
get him elected you also said at the
time you didn't believe that Jeremy
corbyn was anti-semitic do you think
that by being in that shadow cabinet you
were part of the problem
no I don't I think that I mean I
remember both Kia and I were constantly
pushing you know to make sure that we we
adopted the international definition of
anti-semitism you know I know that both
of us pushed that and I know that behind
the scenes we campaigned on it we we did
everything we could to ensure and
eventually succeeded in making sure that
the day party accepted that was the
standard you know we raised the issue
frequently in Shadow cabinet and we
don't normally talk about what happens
in China cabinet but I mean I think that
enough time has gone by to be able to
tell you that it's you know he knows and
both and I know that he did too the two
of us would raise it frequently and make
sure that we kept pushing it we kept
saying what's happened to the
disciplinary process we want to have a
report when are we going to have a
report all of these things happened and
and making sure that we continue to push
it was a very important part you know if
you felt like that yes why did you then
campaign for Jamie Corbin to become
Prime Minister wouldn't that be a red
line for you I think that
I think that it was right for us to be
pushing that and I think that it was
right for us to try to ensure that the
party was was dealt with that problem
you know we did fail but we did try
um I think that a labor government is
always better than a conservative
government I believe that to the bottom
of my soul that I think the labor
government is better I think that that
the way Jeremy led to the anti-semitic
one the way that Jeremy led the labor
party was was one whereby he would he
gave us quite a lot of of freedom to be
able to develop our own briefs and I was
Shadow foreign secretary at the time and
I don't believe that anyone can say that
our foreign policy was in any way
anti-semitic and I use made a speech at
Labor Party Conference
um and there had been before me somebody
speaking about Palestinian cause and to
a sea of Palestinian Flags I said that
there were people who criticized Israel
in a way that cloaked the there deeply
felt anti-Semitism and that that was a
Scourge and that we had to do something
about it and we must reach it out of the
late party and I got a standing ovation
because the vast majority of people in
the late party identified that there was
a problem and wanted it to be dealt with
um I am Keen as today's International
women's day to talk to you a bit about
that just to end the interview as well
it's a one issue I mean the thing is
there's so many issues aren't there that
you could decide to pick but I just
wonder if there's one issue that you
know you feel strongly about that's
personal to you that you think we should
be focusing on today
well yeah there are lots that's the
trouble
um so I think violence against women and
girls is a really important issue I
think that it's in pinches on all our
lives
um and is it it intimidates us and and
uh and limits what we can do because of
a fear
um but I also think that yeah you know
50 years after the Equal Pay Act we
still don't have equal pay how can it be
that women still get 80 of the pay that
men get I mean this is a fact you know
women working full-time we're still
getting 80 why is that and it's partly I
think because you know when Barbara
Castle first introduced the legislation
it was like if two people are doing the
same job then they should both be paid
the same and that was kind of simple but
we've now got into much more complex
areas so we've got things like
like
um
the jobs may be slightly different but
they and therefore are paid differently
and of course there's always the man
who's paid more there's secrecy around
the amount of money that people are paid
it's really difficult to take your case
to a tribunal it's very difficult to
kind of say you know my job is this is
the same or similar to this person's job
and to get a comparison so how we value
classic women's work as well and then
there is the there is the difference in
so you know we saw this during the
pandemic didn't we we saw actually I
think it gave us an opportunity to look
again at what jobs we really value who
are the real core workers who are the
core employees and very often they are
women doing caring roles but they are
the ones who are paid the least have you
ever felt paid unequally in your career
oh that's a good question
um
yes I think there have been times when I
have not been paid the same that's
interesting um yeah no I think so name
any names
um no I mean I think that there were
times when I would do um so when I was
when I was a lawyer there was certain
work that I would be pushed towards that
would be paid less than the work that
that uh that men on the whole did and
then I started doing it and I turned up
and I would be the only one doing so
fraud cases for example I used to be the
only woman ever doing fraud cases and
they were paid much better than the
other type of criminal defense work that
I was doing and you know there were all
these guys in double-breasted suits of
me
um and that was unusual you know but
they had kind of cornered the market
although we were all doing criminal
defense work you know there were certain
parts of the of crime that that men
would do and women wouldn't really
interesting and thanks very much for
coming the program today not at all
we'll be talking more about
International women's day later on the
program but next up we're going to be
talking to some coats about his latest
Westminster accounts investigation
[Music]
welcome back to Westminster a Sky News
investigation can tonight reveal the
former prime minister Boris Johnson has
earned 85 percent of all the outside
earnings generated by MPS this year
adaptive political editor some coats has
the latest edition of the Westminster
accounts
the most famous face in British politics
this week's six months since Boris
Johnson was forced to leave number 10.
in resignation he promised the nation
there were good times ahead even if
things can sometimes seem dark now
our future together is golden for him it
certainly has been here are the MPS who
have declared the most in outside
earnings so far in this Parliament and
at the top it's not even close nearly
five million pounds in earnings for
Boris Johnson almost all of that earned
in the six short months since he
departed Downing Street
at 22 million pounds now that's the
total amount of money all 650 MPS have
declared on top of their 84 000 pounds a
year salary since the last election in
December 2019 and here are the MPS that
have registered the most in outside
income so far in 2023 so we've got the
data for just under two months of
earnings now understandably many of
these numbers are quite small but one
man clearly is having a very good year
financially at least the former prime
minister has registered over 3.7 million
pounds in extra income just since the
third of the year he's been paid over
500 000 pounds by publisher Harper
Collins for a book that's yet to be
published a nearly two and a half
million pounds from an agency which the
former prime minister describes as an
advance for speaking engagements now the
sheer scale of Boris Johnson's earnings
are really rather extraordinary so look
at this 4.4 million pounds is the total
sum of outside earnings made by all 650
MPS so far in 2023 and of that figure
Boris Johnson alone has earned 85 of the
cash
a highly paid speaking gigs have spanned
Singapore New York and Mumbai and now
Westminster North Parliament this a
conference just down the road Boris
Johnson giving his first public reaction
to rishi's next brexit deal what just
happens to be a very lucrative platform
Boris Johnson how much are they paying
you to pronounce at the brand Finance
conference why aren't you doing this in
Parliament
Uxbridge in West London is where Boris
Johnson has made his political home this
is not a safe seat some constituents far
from Happy do you think he should stand
again and if you if he did would you
vote for him
um
no I don't think I'd vote for him again
um he's making a lot of money like you
say doing other things so yeah step down
I'm okay with that but I wanted him to
focus more on his constituency I'm here
working six days a week but I never see
him being slung out of office by his own
party doesn't appear to have dented
Boris Johnson's earning power but is
this the golden feature he dreamed of
Sam Coates Sky News
let's chat to Sam a little bit more now
shall we about his report and Sam I
remember talking to you about the whole
Westminster accounts project and one of
the most interesting things about it all
useful things is the fact that you can
compare other MPS against each other and
I guess what's astonishing here is how
much of an outlier Boris Johnson really
is that's right one of the things that
the Westminster account tool does and by
the way you can look at it yourself on
the Sky News app is allow you to compare
and also do leaderboards and you
actually saw one of the leaderboards in
that film just there lists all of the
top earners and what's significant is
that we've got a new name at the top in
January it was Theresa May now it's
Boris Johnson by quite some way I mean
uh trees may have been left quite quite
a long way behind now it's very very
important to stress that Boris Johnson's
done nothing against any rules he's
declared everything properly but as with
Boris Johnson so often what he's done is
taken the rules and really sort of
stretched them to the furthest extent
that you can take it it's been something
he's done all his career and I think it
is one of those issues where people have
very strong views some people don't
think it's a particular issue if you can
get that money then find others uh think
that that's not right but it does test
the boundaries and it also raises
questions about whether or not just the
sheer extent of this doesn't raise
questions about whether or not MPS can
better police themselves and I was just
winding back a little bit through
history because it was in November 2021
that the then prime minister actually
suggested curbs and I've got the letter
from Boris Johnson here it was in the
middle of another Scandal that one was
to do with Owen Patterson and the prime
minister of the day wrote that outside
activities should be undertaken within
reasonable limits and shouldn't prevent
MPS from fulling out fully carrying out
a range of Duties and this
recommendation from the basis of a viral
approach that was what Boris Johnson
suggested then but fast forward a couple
of years and the fact that he then had
to abandon those reforms is now
benefiting himself I wonder what the
abortions of that letter would make of
the current Boris Johnson's earnings
dealing with the problem on the doorstep
at the moment as ever
Sam thanks very much for talking through
that
and now you can they are oh where are we
here no here sorry here we go apologies
for that look in the right place always
useful you can find out more about the
Westminster accounts uh project which is
between Sky News and tortoise meter
media and use our special online tool as
well by visiting Sky news.com or on the
Sky News app
you're watching the take we're live in
Westminster for you it's International
women's day so we're going to be
speaking to a voice from business about
how women with family responsibilities
are being denied promotion and career
progression
hello welcome back to Westminster you're
watching the take now today is
international women's day and I've been
really Keen to do something about it on
the program to Market and we saw a
really interesting piece of research
from the British Chambers of Commerce
we've been looking at the impact of
child care and also the menopause on
women's careers and they say the women
that they've spoken to say they're
missing out on promotion because they
take time off for some of these uh
reasons disproportionately for than men
but also of course the impact that Chaka
has on their career too I've been
speaking to Siobhan Haviland who is the
director general of the British Chambers
of Commerce
I should comment you are dressed
absolutely respondedly tonight you've
been at an event have you uh thank you I
have I was at the palace at lunchtime uh
with the queen consort I'm a trustee of
women of the world and she is the patron
so we had a lovely uh hour in the long
Gallery with her and talking about
hopefully getting to gender equality
amazing and you've got some research out
today uh haven't you just explain what
does it show yeah so this is the first
time the British chose of Commerce have
done this research 4 000 respondents
both men and women looking at their
Career Development
um so run really interesting findings uh
two-thirds of women still say that they
have been impacted in their career
journey through Child Care
responsibilities
over 80 of people don't believe there's
enough support for more General caring
responsibilities and 50 of women are
worried about how menopause is going to
impact them so
it feels like this is an issue that
we're only really recently starting to
talk about I mean I certainly feel that
as a woman like this is something that
it's really only become on the national
conscience I mean other than the people
going through it or who have gone
through it quite recently yeah
definitely I mean having been in
business and in government it's really
only been the last I would say maximum
five years where you see people talking
about it and we see much more through
our chamber Network them talking about
it because it's what businesses want to
talk about and obviously women and men
of course
um and you know there's the whole piece
around understanding understanding how
it impacts people doesn't everyone of
course uh training around that
supporting and then having to sort of
think about how you can work in
flexibility around helping people who
are going through that but it's just
great that people are talking about it
so people begin to understand it's
something they need to learn about and
then child care as well is such a huge
thing I mean it should be for both
parents obviously but in reality it's
often women's whose careers are impacted
by this and that I guess that's what
your researchers has found yeah yeah it
absolutely is and what we found is
that impact is because it's very hard
for women to find affordable child care
you have to be earning a certain salary
before it's really worth you you know
going back to work so it's about
affordable child care it's about
accessible child care because it's also
quite hard to find if you can find it so
you know what we want to do is say we've
looked at all these issues you know
these aren't there aren't quick fixes we
want to have a sort of three-year
campaign where we can put together a an
equity commission we can say okay let's
bring employers together with government
with with their employment experts what
are the policies that government can put
in place what are the best practice that
that business can put in place and how
can we really move the needle and it's
interesting you said that man as well as
women did you find a bit of a gender gap
should we say on whether or not people
felt that child care and having kids had
impacted their careers it was definitely
more women who saw an impact on their
career when it came to child care than
men in fact the Gap really closed when
it came to more General caring
responsibilities which you know you
assume are sort of probably parents
elderly relatives yeah and families and
friends
um there was a much you know there were
86 percent of people saying there's not
enough support around that General
caring piece
um and you know you hear from women more
and more who probably have both Child
Care responsibilities and caring for
parents at the same time so that's a
double impact
um but you know we've got the budget
next week yeah were you hoping to see in
it then so we are you know there's 1.1
million open roles in the UK 50 of our
businesses say they are struggling to
recruit people so you know Chancellor we
really want to look at ways of bringing
people back into the work Force about
1.7 million people don't work because of
caring responsibilities
86 of them are women now of course not
all of them want to work but actually
you know if you can have access to
affordable child care yeah you have that
option so what we want to see is the
chance to look at things like the
current tax-free allowance of two
thousand pounds he could raise that he
could work in other ways of using the
tax system to help couples uh with tax
you know Child Care get attacks or if
you're self-employed for example through
business expenses so we would love to
see him act on Child Care uh next week
um I'm going to ask a bit of a personal
question because your mother as well and
I know that we've sort of spoken a bit
about this um off camera
do you feel that your career has been
impacted by having kids
so my kids are a little bit older now
but
um yeah I mean I was I was in a really
privileged position that by the time I
came to have children I was sort of well
paid enough that I could afford child
care and go back to work both of them
after about nine months but I definitely
saw my celery Plateau during those
probably four or five years and that was
a point at which my husband's salary
overtook mine and often there's critical
moments in your career right when you're
just getting like you said you just got
to a certain level you about you've got
the experience and then suddenly you're
like say kind of plateauing yeah and and
actually when maybe when the when your
partner's earning more than it generally
was falls on you to take the calls from
the school when it's gone gone wrong
um I'm very lucky to have a very
supportive husband but yeah yeah it's
always a Juggle is how it is exactly
yeah I remember getting the advice that
you know if you managed to kind of stand
still in your career when you've got
four children under five then that's an
achievement in itself yeah which is not
what we want in our labor force is it
you know it's not it is great of course
for women who want to go back to work
but it's about the economy yeah it's
about that sort of wasted talent that
could be back in our Workforce but at
the moment we really really need so how
do we support those women who want to go
back back to work to be able to do what
they want to do and give back to the
economy and also good child care I guess
as well right not just any old child
care but child care that is actually
somewhere that you might feel
comfortable leaving your children and
not feel the kind of guilt that all
mothers and fathers tend to yeah feel
absolutely right a choice of types of
child care that suits as well you
probably work flexibly you know you
might work different hours different
relationship day shift you know we need
options for child care absolutely uh
really great to have on the program
thanks very much for coming in thank you
very much you too
[Music]
welcome back we've had lots of takes
this evening and for our very final take
we're joined by our chief political
correspondent John Craig and you've got
a couple of news stories to bring us up
to date with the first is about lobbying
right a couple of breaking stories
really which may well develop tomorrow
uh the first one is from the telegraph's
lockdown files but it's not about Matt
Hancock it's about another ex-minister
that's Steve Bryan now he was a junior
minister at Health under Jeremy Hunt but
crucially he now chairs the health
select committee and he has been found
out if you like by the what's leaked
whatsapps because he was lobbying for a
firm that was paying him sixteen hundred
pounds a month it's a it's a company
called remedium it's a recruitment
company and he was trying to persuade
the NHS to hire people through this firm
a WhatsApp said long story short I've
been trying for months to help the NHS
through a company company I'm connected
with he sent that to Michael Gove and to
Simon Stevens the boss of NHS England
now the liberal Democrats say you should
stand down as chairman of that select
committee the health select committee
this is Daisy Cooper their health
spokesperson yet another conservative
Scandal she says Steve Bryan should
immediately step down from the health
select committee and the PM should
launch an independent investigation into
this damning evidence Brian cannot be
imposed while these allegations hang
over his head well he says he's done
nothing wrong he told the telegraph
actually this was about responding in
the National interest to an urgent
public call for ministers in the NHS in
a national crisis now we're very very
nearly out of time but Boris Johnson has
waded into the dominant Rob case this is
also in the Daily Telegraph Boris
Johnson warned Dominic Robb about his
conduct and gave evidence to bullying
investigation now Mr Johnson's been
terribly busy earning all that money
that Sam was talking about but he found
time we learned to talk to Adam Ollie
Casey who's carrying out that bullying
inquiry you'll remember you interviewed
Dominic Robb he said if he was found
guilty he'd quit well it's claimed that
Boris Johnson warned him about his
contact very helpful not very helpful we
are out of time that's it for the tape
we'll be back next week and every week
Wednesdays at 9pm
[Music]
foreign